[Musique]
nos petits compagnons à quatre pattes se
sont donnés rendez vous ce samedi 12 mai
au jardin de l'état afin de trouver
leurs familles pour la vie le
département a mis le site à disposition
de deux associations la société
protectrice des animaux et réunion
protection animale la collectivité
également financé des vaccins des puces
électroniques à remettre aux
propriétaires cette journée en fait
cessé dans le but de faire des adoptions
parce qu'on a beaucoup de difficultés
déjà à se faire connaître et à montrer
tous les chiens qu'on à l'adoption
il faut savoir s'ils sont des chiens
pour sauver aux quatre coins de l'île
issu de sauvetage voir certains de
maltraitance sur le stand 2k
on a une dizaine de jours on a quatre
chatons et des chiens adultes
pour la présidente du département il est
très important de soutenir ces
associations est de sensibiliser les
réunionnais à la bientraitance animan ya
deux ans à l'arraché je pense que m
les accompagner pour qu'ils puissent se
faire leur travail pour puis le travail
de sensibilisation à l'égard au fond des
plus jeunes comme des oiseaux il faut
aimer les
nous pas pour soi il faut aussi avant
tout les maîtres eux
une manifestation qui a rencontré un
succès puisque de nombreux chiens chats
ont été adoptés je pense qu'il ya des
endroits effectivement le commerce
d'animaux peu fonctionnels notamment en
métropole mais à la réunion une
problématique qui est complètement
différent c'est que nos animaux sauvages
ce sont des chiens et je pense que ce
genre d'initiative
ça permet de
diminués déjà le nombre de chiens
errants et surtout de sauver de
maltraitance le chat qui j'ai craqué sur
ce petit e beauté là ça permet de me
retrouver en famille de les rendre
heureux quoi dernier retrouvés il ya
quelques mois brûlée au troisième degré
est encore à la recherche d'une famille
aimante
alors rendez vous ce samedi au jardin de
l'état jusqu'à 17 heures
[Musique]